jack wagner's son harrison dead at 27.
according to the los angeles county
coroner's report harrison died on monday
in a parking lot
his manner and cause of death have yet
to be determined
an autopsy is scheduled and an
investigator has been assigned to
harrison's case
while jack and his ex-wife christina
wagner grieve their son's death they've
received an outpouring of love on social
media the former couple who met as
co-stars on general hospital received
condolences from their fellow gh star
tristan rogers who tweeted quote my
heart goes out to jack and christina on
the loss of their son as a parent the
loss of a child is my worst nightmare
harrison's final instagram post was may
22nd sitting on a bench looking pensive
his caption focus you are left with you
and your thoughts
earlier that month harrison shared a
series of photos with his mom and
brother peter visiting their family
ranch
all right
[Music]
christina shared the same image and
wrote in the caption
peter and harrison hashtag love my sons
she often shares posts highlighting how
proud she is of her kids like when
harrison ran the pasadena half marathon
in 2018.
how are we doing we ready for this
are we ready for this jerry ready for
this all the way all the way ready for
repeat
harrison is survived by his dad mom
brother and sister carrie
[Music]
you